foreign
in this portion of our world views and
values class we are going to look at
somebody
who has had an incredible amount of
influence on the world in which we
we live today both direct and indirect
and that is rene descartes his his
conception
of the the world of human beings
of body and mind and many other
things as well has radically
changed the face of philosophy from what
it was
in the times previous to him in ancient
and medieval times
in the west and although he doesn't
deserve complete credit for it because
there's no one individual who does
he is very uh involved
in the rise of a sort of modern
scientific conception
of the world and the the quest to figure
out
where human beings fit within that that
new
radically changed picture so we're going
to look at one of his
easier works to to tackle and digest
the discourse on method i'll tell you
why it's one of his easier works in a
few minutes
before that i want to you know remind
you that what are we going to do
in this introductory video there's
always three things that we look at
one of them is the genre of the work
because you want to have a good sense of
what kind of work you're reading
as you're plowing through it the others
will talk a little bit
about the historical context that
descartes is
both growing up and working within and
also changing
and then we will talk about some of the
key themes of the work that you can
expect to see tackled
in the videos that follow this one what
is the genre of this particular work the
discourse on method
so when we think of genre we're talking
about
what sort of writing we're dealing with
and why are we interested in that
because it gives us some clues about
what we ought to be looking for
what we ought to be paying attention to
what kind of expectations we can have
of the author and what expectations the
author has of us
as readers now discourse is not a term
that we use an
awful lot today when we do use it it's
often used to mean speech
or just talking in general we engaged in
discourse if you do discourse analysis
you're studying
other people's conversations or perhaps
your own
in philosophy and in the other
humanities
more generally discourse has a different
meaning
and it what it signifies is that you've
got a text
that is dealing with a particular
subject
and the author is going to try to
develop a fairly systematic
exposition of that subject so it's meant
to be something another synonym for this
would be treatise
it's a philosophical work that aims to
be
systematic not necessarily exhaustive
but certainly to give you the key ideas
the key points the key
arguments the key elements of a
particular perspective
descartes is doing a discourse on method
and we're going to talk about
why method matters for him so much
a little bit later but you want to keep
that in mind the the centerpiece of this
is
i have a new method that i'm presenting
to you
and you know there's there's a bit of
narrative at the beginning there's
actually a lot of narrative running
throughout the work
because he's conveying to us his own
intellectual experiences but he's not
trying to say
um i just had these these ideas uh
these insights and here's the way it was
for me
there's a little bit of well you know it
doesn't necessarily have to be the case
for you but he doesn't mean that
what he's doing is he's offering himself
and the new way that he has thought
things out as a model
for the rest of us and that's what this
discourse is really about
so what we've got here is a mix of
personal narrative
and philosophical argument pretty
important and deep metaphysical argument
and then some discussions of physical
phenomena
that are not that interesting for the
most part to us like the circulation of
the the blood and the heart
in part five and we're actually not
going to pay much attention to to that
let's talk about the narrative what kind
of story is this
so it's not a story of
you know a romance or of a conflict
between you know a protagonist an
antagonist it's really more of something
like a quest
and what is the quest for what is
descartes really
motivated by in this quest he's looking
for knowledge
now you might say well knowledge is easy
to find just go on to wikipedia and
there you've got it
but de descartes is worried
as we want to be in our own time for
different reasons
he's worried in his time about there's
all these claims to knowledge out there
are they really knowledge or are they
just
opinions are they just
things without solid foundations when we
start
plumbing down to the depths and if you
think about this
this is a real serious issue because
anybody can provide explanations but is
the explanation a true explanation does
it really hold up
a lot of what we have come to call
science you know
over time if you look at it carefully
some of it turns out to be reliable
some of it ends up being pseudoscience
or
bunk and we have to throw it aside
so he's dealing with this fundamental
question in the beginning of the modern
period and asking how can i actually
attain
real knowledge there's two other key
things that are associated with this
for descartes to possess knowledge means
to have
certainty it's not just enough to have
the information
you need to be certain that that
information
is actually true is actually
correct is really representing things
the way they truly are so this quest for
certainty and this identification of
knowledge with certainty is something
that's really key to this this
narrative to this quest that he's on
another thing that he's looking for
is a method that will allow him to
build from a solid foundation on up
to all sorts of other disciplines all
sorts of other sciences to attain
practical as well as theoretical results
descartes actually has this beautiful
image
of a tree
where and it's a tree of knowledge the
tree of the disciplines
there's a lot of m's involved in this
metaphysics is the roots of the tree
and physics is the trunk and then the
branches
are things like mechanics and by
mechanics he means everything
you know for that we call technology
all the way to anything where you can
put parts together
and and make it work make it attain some
sort of purpose so engineering would be
part of
mechanics
what else medicine
and by medicine he doesn't just
understand you know going to the doctor
or going to the hospital he understands
what we might call the entire field of
public health
so diet for example diet can be
understood according to the cartesian
method and then morals or what we
oftentimes call
ethics descartes thinks that these are
areas that have not been
at least up to his time properly
understood
because people have had the wrong
methods for
approaching them and if we begin anew
and come up with a better method we can
attain
all sorts of lasting reliable
results and improve human life as a
result
so that's what this book is really about
for him he's presenting
a proposal to us about how we ought to
think how we want to approach
matters how we ought to think about the
entire world how we ought to think about
ourselves
how we ought to think about our relation
to whatever happens to be
transcendent to us
this book is also what we can call a
retrospective
and a summary of his philosophy
up to that point now that doesn't mean
that it's the last book that he wrote as
a matter of fact it's not
but a lot of the key ideas that we're
going to see in his other works
show up in a summary form and get
placed in a kind of context within the
discourse
so what i need to tell you about here
actually strays a little bit into the
historical context part
descartes had a book that he was working
on called the world
and he didn't end up publishing it and
i'll tell you why in a few minutes
he did end up publishing three portions
of it
the meteors which was about you know
meteorological phenomena
the dioptrix and the geometry and this
discourse on method was meant to be
a preface or an introduction to these
three works essentially of what we would
now call
um physics or or applied natural science
except for the geometry of course right
and in it descartes
is presenting his ideas to
a general audience
interestingly this is the one work that
he's going to
at that point in his career write in
french
because descartes although he's a
frenchman like everybody else who's
educated at the time
knows latin and so he writes most of his
works in latin
and then they're translated into french
not by him by the way but by
by other people this book he writes in
french and why does he write it in
french
because he wants to reach a general
audience
which even as he says includes women
it's important to remember
that women did not enjoy the same sort
of equality
uh that they enjoyed today uh in in
you know the field of education or the
professions or any of those sorts of
things
that wasn't the case back then so
descartes is
writing this in french because he can't
assume that most women
are going to have the kind of education
that
his other books would presume before
they're translated
but he wants to reach women and it's an
interesting thing that why does he want
to do that because he considers them
essentially to be on the same level as
as men so
this is a like i said a retrospective
and summary of his his philosophy
um it's good to think about this in
context of some of his
other works so what would some of those
other works be he by this time he'd
already written a book called the rules
for the direction of the mind published
in latin
he's about to bring out his meditations
on first philosophy
in which you're going to see a lot of
the same themes as
in the discourse dealt with but in a
longer more detailed in some ways deeper
um and and providing more argument sort
of form
he will also write a principles of
philosophy later on that's that intended
to be a textbook
pretty tough textbook if you read it and
then finally towards the end of his life
he writes a book called the passions of
the soul where he's trying to explain
the mind-body interaction
he wrote a lot of letters in his
lifetime as well
uh if you want to study descartes
further it's very
useful to look at some of that
correspondence as a matter of fact
there's there's a correspondence with
princess elizabeth that
ties directly to the passions of the
soul and to many of his other works
that uh is very illuminating but as far
as this work goes the the discourse
what you've got here is a
fairly short concise work discussing
his philosophy in its general terms
as far as this class goes here's the
last thing that i want to say about
genre as far as this class goes
i think it's very important that you
read parts one through four
very carefully a good portion of
part five you can skip over because he's
concerned there
with explaining some of his his ideas
about
mechanics and medicine and it's not
stuff that's particularly
interesting or irrelevant to us today
except where he gets to talking about
minds and machines and animals towards
the end of
part five and then part six you can read
it or or not i'm not actually going to
discuss it much in these videos
because it's not uh especially important
as far as descartes philosophy goes he's
sort of showing applications
and he's also discussing something that
fits in with the historical context
which is the galileo incident
so that is the the enough about the
genre of the work let's think
now about the historical context in
which descartes
is living and thinking
and writing and it is an incredibly
heady time that he is is working and
very very interesting that's why
i highly recommend you know studying the
history of the
these thinkers because descartes is not
only being
formed by the historical context that
he's in he's also contributing to
steering it
going in certain directions and although
he
attempted to be as uncontroversial of a
figure as possible he ends up sparking
all sorts of controversies
and being involved in many of them as
well
so what can we say about the historical
context if we're going to
sketch things out in very broad terms
and that's really what we have to do
uh in in this video so that we don't get
too bogged down into the details
one of the things that we can talk about
is the intellectual life
of descartes time that's a good sort of
lens through which to look at what's
going on
and we can talk about the effects of the
renaissance
and then the reformation and the entire
humanist period that that's that's
passing through them
that had an immense influence so
what was the renaissance it was a
rediscovery
in part of ancient philosophy
you know stoicism had been largely
underground
epicureanism a lot of these texts are
now coming to light being translated
people are are engaging in in new ways
of trying to think about
matter about physical phenomenon about
the human
body about society and
they're departing from the the older
traditions
which by that time would be not only you
know sort of what we can call a
platonist or augustinian tradition
um you know which was very deeply
influential within within the catholic
church which had
an immense role within european society
but also aristotelian
philosophy which by that time had come
to
largely dominate the educational
institutions
of the universities and even you know
what we could call nowadays preparatory
schools
that were places where you would go to
get an education so
then you could go further on to the
universities
what we've got going on is a number of
new initiatives where people are
on the one hand trying to take these old
older models of philosophy
from antiquity some of them developed
further in in the middle ages
and see whether they can make sense of
the world in which they're living so
that includes the world
physical phenomenon ideas about god
ideas about the heavens
ideas about the human being and ideas
about society
so descartes is at the center of this
you can see
a profound influence on his philosophy
coming from stoicism you can also see
influences on him coming from
augustine coming from other figures and
you can see him reacting very
strongly against what had become
the sort of party line of aristotelian
philosophy
by the way here's a side note the
aristotelianism
of the late middle ages was not
particularly good or
faithful aristotle it's not as if they
were really approaching things in
aristotelian way
the late scholasticism had become rather
more abund
and you know that's why the word
scholastic
has become kind of a byword a pejorative
term
so you say somebody's work is very
scholastic you mean that they're doing
nitpicky
distinctions that don't really matter
much they're engaged in a lot of
thomas hobbs said jingling with words
rather than attending to things
so descartes is in part reacting against
that
if we mix into that something else that
that was going on at the same time
things get even more complicated and
that's the reformation
the protestant reformation shook europe
to its very core
and not only in the world of you know
say religion or how we should do things
in church or what church we ought to go
to
but also in the world of literature
history philosophy all these things said
shock waves through that and even
further into the world of
politics and everyday life
so you know for example descartes is
going to grow up in a part of france
which although he's a catholic is
actually dominated
by by protestants at that time and he's
going to end up going to a jesuit so
it's catholic school
the jesuits were always a little suspect
though they were either like too
conservative or too radical for most of
the other catholics
so there's all these amazing things
going on
all these interesting divisions and
these people
wrote and thought and talked to each
other for these people
religious ideas mattered
they really thought that it was
important
whether one focused on you know just
scripture alone
or attended to tradition whether one
thought that there were
two sacraments or whether there weren't
really any sacraments at all just
observances
or or ordinances or whether there were
seven sacraments these were
the sorts of things that people really
thought
uh one ought to give a lot of thought to
at the same time
there was also a movement towards what
we call free thinking or libertarianism
or atheism going on
there were people who were deists
descartes was probably one of them
who thought that god gets everything
started and then sort of says hands off
and leaves things up to us human beings
to figure out
so that we don't need religious
institutions
so there's a lot of ferment going on in
intellectual life and a lot of
sort of like hold the line doctrinaire
stultification and descartes is very
clearly on the side of innovation
uh and against the just keep doing
things the way that they've been done
sort of party line at the same time
descartes
is also not somebody who wants to change
things just for the sake of changing
them
his project is to try to figure out how
we could
put an end to all this bickering and
arguing
and debating by attaining some sort of
basis of certainty
that we could you know say if we want to
be very crude
look all of you just shut up here's
where we have to start from
quit arguing with each other learn the
basis and then let's build together
a brand new society another thing that's
going on at the time
that's coinciding with all of this is
the rise of what we call
modern science and there was a lot of
experimentation going on a lot of
theorizing about the nature
of reality about the nature of material
objects and their processes
physics the science of of change or
motion
um chemistry was beginning to develop at
that time
there were a lot of biological ideas
that were you know beginning to
float around although they were not
doing all that much experimentation
they actually did did things like that
they were beginning to know a lot more
about the human body and its workings
because they were
doing things like dissecting cadavers
and looking to see
what's actually in this this thing so
descartes himself is
learning the best science available at
his time
he's also a major contributor
to the developing sciences particularly
mathematics
if you've ever heard of cartesian
coordinates or analytic geometry
descartes is the guy who who synthesized
the ideas
that were required for that to happen if
you've ever taken a calculus class
descartes didn't come up with calculus
that was
leibniz and newton later on
independently of each other by the way
but descartes laid the groundwork that
made it possible
for these further advances in geometry
and arithmetic
and mathematics as a whole to occur
he's very interested in the nature of
the body
and how it connects with with the mind
and when we look at his science
we might say well a lot of that's pretty
unbelievable given what we know now
but that's how science advances people
come up with new theories
new ideas test them out and they
try to come up with the best account at
the
possible at the time and you know
eventually it gets
if it's not sufficient replaced by
better accounts
but those better accounts use the
earlier accounts as their sort of
staging grounds
for making advances and descartes is
deeply involved in that
um so he's involved in intellectual life
he's involved in science
um one of the things that we do have to
mention that that
that really had a major influence on
descartes career
is the galileo incident and i'm not
going to go into any great detail about
this
other than to say that
you know it's not so simple as well the
church just came down on galileo and
they were
so mean and and you know bigoted and
closed-minded
galileo did a lot of pushing on his own
part if you if you actually read
about what took place and not all not
all catholics thought that condemning
galileo was a good idea as a matter of
fact blaise pascal one of descartes
contemporary said really bad idea guys
this is not what you ought to be doing
be it as it may um galileo advances some
new
theories about the nature of the
universe
about about the the way things are so
he's advancing a new world view
and descartes to a large extent shares
that world view
as a matter of fact while galileo is
starting to run into problems with
authorities and going through all these
things are going to lead to his house
arrest
descartes is working on a book called
the world and it's supposed to be a
system that explains all the physical
phenomenon
as far as he knows within the world
when galileo gets condemned descartes
says oh
i better back off from this sort of
thing what can i salvage from this
project
and that's where these these three
treaties is that the discourse on method
is an introduction to are going to come
out so the world itself doesn't get
published
not in its entirety until until much
much later
and descartes is seeing this as sort of
a sign that
i'd better make sure that i stay out of
trouble so you'll see a lot of
professions
on descartes part that he's a faithful
catholic that he's not going against
church doctrine
that as a matter of fact this philosophy
is going to be better for church
doctrine than aristotle or thomas
aquinas or any of these sort of people
and a lot of that most scholars think is
kind of you know cya or window
addressing you know what cia
cya stands for i think um
really when it comes down to it
descartes is interested in advancing
a new way of looking at at the world at
the body
at the mind and
he will do whatever he needs to do to
adapt himself to the situation that he's
in which includes
one in which religious persecution is an
option
um he does go to live for the most part
in in a country in a protestant country
but
a protestant country in which free
thinking has allowed
um the netherlands he spends a lot of
his adult life there
after being a mercenary soldier in the
wars of religion by the way
where he doesn't actually see much
action towards the very end of his life
he ends up moving to sweden uh he's he's
invited to give
give tutorials to to the queen of sweden
they don't go particularly well
he's not there for a long time before he
gets sick and dies
but in the meantime he's developed this
incredible
new philosophical system this new
philosophical approach to things
and he ends up having an immense
influence both on those who
would be called cartesians those who are
following in his footsteps
and trying to work out that kind of
philosophy which would include people
like benedict spinoza
or nicholas mall brush or gottfried
wilhelm leibniz
but he also influences those who argue
against him
who take all other positions that that
he
doesn't think are right but they think
are right because he's seen as somebody
who you have to grapple with somebody
who you have to
address that that's one way you can tell
that somebody's made a very big
impact that when people want to propose
something else they have to say
that's why this guy over here is wrong
and why i'm
i'm right so that's the historical
context for
this work what are the key themes of
this
great work the discourse on method
if we look at them we're going to see
that many of these are not only key
themes of that particular work they're
key themes of descartes philosophy
as a whole and probably the one that we
ought to begin with is descartes
most famous saying the thing that if
people only remember one thing about
this guy
it's this which is i think therefore i
am and there's really two important sort
of
sub points to that one is that this is
the archimedean point
as descartes calls it that allows him to
move everything else this is the one
thing that he says
we cannot doubt at all because
in the very act of doubting it it's
clear to us that
this is the case the other thing is it
points out to us
i think i am a thinking substance
that is the nature of what it is to be a
human being for descartes
to be a thing that thinks um what else
can we talk about
well another key theme of this here is
of
carrying out a kind of review of the
education
of the sciences of the disciplines all
the claimants to knowledge
of his time putting them into the
balance and seeing whether they really
measure up whether they can deliver the
results that correspond to their
promises so that's another key theme
another major one is that if we want to
attain
certainty what we have to do is blaze a
new path
that begins with us that begins with
turning inward to our own minds
not paying attention to what people in
the past have said
and just following in their footsteps
but
for once in in our existence actually
stopping and saying what do i know what
can
i come up with how are things for me and
we would call that
sort of a return to inwardness or
subjectivity
another super important theme is this
notion that
if we want to make progress we need some
sort of
method and if we have a good method
then we will be able to figure out
everything that matters so this reliance
on on method in in philosophy
is very cartesian
one of the key elements of that method
is that it includes
what we call hyperbolic or
methodological
doubt that is saying that if we can
doubt something
that we're going to reject it that we're
going to be skeptical about it that
we're not going to
accept it just on the basis of you know
versimilitude or somebody else's say so
or the fact that people have done that
and and we're going to extend this doubt
really far to to the point where we can
say
perhaps this is all a dream or if i
can't figure out how
how this is different than a dream i'd
better reject not only my dreams but my
waking reality as well
another key theme would be the reliance
on this criterion
of clear and distinct ideas
as the touchstone for whether something
is true whether we have genuine
knowledge whether we can
rely upon it another important theme
one that is is probably up there with
the most
central themes of descartes philosophy
is a very strong distinction
between body on the one hand and mind on
the other
what we call a dualism of body and mind
the difficulty then is to figure out how
they actually intersect and interact
uh and we won't get an awful lot of this
in in
the discourse although he talks about
that in other words but
we are going to focus a lot on the
distinction between
body and and mind um
there's also some important discussion
about god
you can probably say that descartes was
was a deist he's not
really a a religious believer in the way
that a lot of people are today
he's more focused on god as a
metaphysical principle and we're going
to see how that matters
in his philosophy and how that fits in
the emphasis on sort of neo-stoic that
is
that is stoic but but understood through
a different lens
ideas in morality is also distinctively
cartesian
and the last theme that i want to hit on
is
there are some important implications
about the differences between human
beings
who have minds on the one hand and
machines and animals on the other hand
for descartes
which do not possess minds so these are
all the the big
picture themes that are running through
this work and we're going to look at
quite a few of these in the videos to
come